bom dia pessoal mariana barbosa
jornalista ae se hoje sou jornalista não
é como escrever sobre as dores
é o que estão fazendo hoje é a primeira
vez que como é que faz para mudar o chá
os sites podem mudar em cima
boa tarde é quando o convidou para fazer
esta toca e comecei a pensar no que eu
poderia falar e e e lembrarmos da ideia
de uma coisa que eu pedi no 10º ano em
português eu era boa aluna que estava
muito de português e 40 dos irmãos
partido para enviar a hipótese pode ser
uma peça uma seca mas eu aprendi que os
peixes não sei se alguém sabe como é que
é bom que os peixes que estão à volta do
tubarão chamas regras remoção para
visitas a sociedade para antónio vieira
falava disso os irmãos país a propósito
da crítica social do como é que como é
como é que as câmeras sobrevivem graças
à altura o tubarão protege e além disso
aqui o que trará um deixa deixa de sobra
já que como as regras limitam disso o
jornalista joão carinha cinco
jornalistas são além de nossa história
das pessoas e eu sinto um carinho rêmora
anos sente o tempo a andar
a brigada mais tempo não é obrigado é é
é esse o papa histórias porque os
jornalistas são as regras mas depois eu
também pensei preciso na lista eram
removidas porque porque se alimentam de
histórias contam histórias
os dois também são por quando estava a
preparar esta top e última lei sobre as
regras e percebi que as regras além de
se alimentarem de serem parasitas se
alimentarem de daquilo que os restos das
histórias dos outros conseguem prever é
o percurso canal vai fazer que vai fazer
o site já tem um grau de previsibilidade
grande e antecipam o futuro e os pés do
chão em si mesmo fazer o show
empreendedores são pessoas sobre as
quais escreve histórias de pessoas que
criam negócios que são futuros
unicórnios são pessoas inspiradoras são
pessoas como o inseto particular
é no calendário for boa é portanto nunca
poderia falar é de mim sem falar nos
fase 2 a 8 anos que sou jornalista que
escreve histórias de fazer hoje primeiro
dia viveu foi convidada a integrar a
relação do dinheiro vivo a em 2011 na
altura em que o jornal foi fundado um
dia viveram uma uma marca da economia
completamente diz cultiva a fama marca
incluída na secção de economia de ler um
jornal histórico com mais de 150 anos e
ii natura criar uma marca na economia a
parte clínica graça é a relação do
jornal
com uma estrutura super pesada um jornal
antigo com pessoas que é uma vez a
mudança fez com que nós fossemos uma
lufada de ar fresco mas também os
primeiros em mix a bater no entanto
andré quando me convidaram mas e quando
o convidou para integrar a relação do
dinheiro vivo escrever sobre as dores em
2011 como fazer o cálculo não é via
muito pouca gente a falar sobre
empreendedorismo em portugal
a uneb foi o primeiro meio de
comunicação social é ter uma secção
específica que só falava de fase 2 a
secção prima chamava se faz por pessoa
chamada de fase 2 porque eu digo às duas
vítimas aqui nos açores enquanto e é
criou se uma queda de criciúma vivo de
confiança e de contactos cada vez que o
entrevistaram fazedor esfacelava o
contacto de outro fator que depois de
entrevistar e censurou uma viúva que
conta com mais de mil fãs duas mil
pessoas que entrevistei milhares de
horas de entrevistas milhões de t trans
crítica como ficar com muitas muitas
histórias para contar
obrigada
e isso é uma outra questão é como é que
eu poderia falar de uma de uma de uma
ideia aqui e maíra que fosse
é interessante e que ao mesmo tempo
fosse antagônica que o que eu faço
normalmente como vocês cálculo no
jornalismo
nós usamos um método que chama a tv 1a
invertida
quer dizer que você imagina uma pirâmide
quer dizer que a notícia é que o que é
mais interessante na história está no
primeiro parágrafo que vai escutando que
a medida fosse um custo baixo para cima
não faz mal à proposta enquanto
continuam conhecer a história continua
conhecer a notícia
o que queima o que me desafiaram a fazer
foi exatamente o contrário
ficou um câncer difícil né e portanto
como é que gera empatia neste caso eu
queria te ver daqui
quem é que já pensou fundar um negócio o
cliente a fundo e vitória
e quem é que conhece gente fazendo a
gente que já criou um negócio muito bem
o que eu escrevo e é aí que fizera
empatia porque a partir do momento em
que nós conhecemos histórias e lendas e
histórias de pessoas e reconhecemos
nelas coisas que nós já fizemos fazer as
coisas que alguém que nós conhecemos
fizeram isso gera empatia tanto a minha
idéia é sim eu quero for os fazedores
por toda a importância de fazer dois
tiveram é no país e na minha vida que é
pôr os fazedores no dicionário que é
problema fazendo no dicionário
só que foi logo à partida porque eu
descobri o cenário já existe
a primeira que faz parte né
mas o que também percebi é que se calhar
o miguel santa maria em flashes a
piscina é fã secretário critica o jaime
jorge da caldas e todos os mais de mil
empreendedores em entrevista ao longo
dos últimos oito anos não se revê neste
conceito do fazedor é que eu que faço e
escuta porque o torcedor é muito mais do
que isso eu aprendi que o fazedor é uma
pessoa assim que escutou obviamente é
uma pessoa que pensa uma idéia
concretize essa ideia que agrega pessoas
que constrói comunidade
portanto uma das coisas que eu aprendi
também é que a idéia nunca é mais
importante que a monte de gente nem
tanto mas eu gostava tanto fundar um
negócio não tem uma ideia como é que eu
como é que eu vou falar um negócio uma
ideia tudo conhece tudo que estamos
fazendo já uma ideia de criar um negócio
mas ainda não é o mais importante se eu
aprendi com ele não há mais importante o
mais importante é a maneira como se
fazem as coisas e as pessoas que nós
desenvolvemos a nossa história em
portugal nos últimos oito anos mudou
tudo o que eram
em 2000 no ano 2000 criaram-se duas
incubadoras em portugal abriram duas
incubadoras em 2013 13 e comunicadoras
em 2016 19 incubadoras
imagine como é que se transcreve no bem
um mapa e escreve se assim em centenas
de bolinhas ou mais 165 voadora de
exploradores em portugal e isso tem um
impacto enorme também na maneira como as
pessoas na facilidade com que as pessoas
podem criar negócios podem construir
valor podem ganhar dinheiro e podem
inspirar outras pessoas a fazerem o
mesmo
achei importante dos últimos anos
nasceram entidades que podem ajudar a
fazer este percurso não só de torcedores
mas também o projeto está portugal um
projecto um projecto de apoio ao
ecossistema português
a rede nacional de inclusão da cidade no
ranking nacional de corredores do ano
passado serão imensos projectos em
portugal e encheram mecanismos e
instituições que podem apoiar este
projecto é o cheiro não é tão diferente
do nosso trabalho eu propus tendo em
conta que havia tanta coisa acontecendo
no país eu propus que sentimos um
carinho de lisboa do porto e do braga
que é um grande pólo agregador e e mais
conhecido como project e pudéssemos
fazer uma volta a portugal incubadoras
da primeira fase volta a portugal a
primeira decisão do ano passado época
idéias em corredores norte a sul do país
mais natural do que no interior e em
janeiro vou voltar à estrada pra fazer
mais 10
fazer reportagens e dar voz a estes
fazedores esses empreendedores estão
mais do que mais do que a de construir
patrimônio é construir jogadas estão
mudar a maneira como os portugueses vêem
e como nós nos vemos de como o pai e
como usou spray país nos vem ao longo
dos anos eu percebi também e essa é a
ilustração foi feita em dinheiro vivo
foi de plano e orçamento que trabalhava
connosco num em entre nós fazemos um
guia todos os anos de de fazer dois com
os melhores fazedores do ano ea menor
que fazia sempre ilustrações e assim
construção foi feita pra conhecer guia é
a ideia é exatamente esta um canivete
português é o faz-tudo português é é
aliar a nossa capacidade desenrasca que
toda a gente e hoje nós já temos os
estrangeiros nas ruas carlos brito conta
que tudo é alguma a formação ao mundo há
pessoas que estiveram fora que voltaram
a pessoas que estão cá é mudar a mudar
comunidade onde está inserida a mudar o
sítio onde vivem é mudar o mundo
a boa funciona o be é importante para
dar alguma maneira sua área e fechar
esse de quase dez anos em que sou
fazedor de lançar um livro sai eu sei
que o guia de de orador bicho pra nós
não falamos isso não está nas capas do
espero nunca precisar de capas livros
não vou estar na capa do livro lançado
ontem que vai apresentar ontem no porto
e vovô apresentado em lisboa também no
resto do país chávez o livro de fase 2 e
uma das missões da ação 15 entrevistas e
uma das missões finais fase 2 da eeb que
um fazedor é o antigo é dos teus irmãos
do rei do tio falar porque é o velho o
selo era é que eu estava quando
descobriu os portugueses iam foram
conhecer o mundo leva a descobrir o
mundo
é o pessimismo e o pedro é dada nem de
obras de 51 favor é onde velho cresceu
porque porque o fazedor diz não vai vai
vai e o vôo antigo outras dimensões de
fazedores que a fifa que a fifa neto
xique-xique estado cujo projecto acabou
por enquanto não faz nada não faz normal
haver essa é que enquanto não tenta tu
nunca falha não é nada pode correr mal
porque eu não faço nada é muito
interessante de contar as histórias de
fase 2 porque sinto que a partir do
momento em que nos encontramos essas
histórias nos tornarmos capacitamos as
outras pessoas de podem ser capazes de
construir sua própria história que
construiu sua própria empresa de fundar
seu próprio negócio e e à medida que
esta regra vai alimentando as nossas
histórias vai ser possível mudar é uma
em 7 do bahia sintaj eu acredito que
podemos mudar através dos fazedores
podemos mudar uma e sete no país inteiro
porque porque estes roedores chão é
inspirador para mim e tem sido
inspirador para as outras pessoas
como é que nós continuamos a contar as
suas histórias
eu acho que é muito ontem no caminho pra
cá vinha a pensar é na quantidade de
coisas que nós fizemos e no pouco tempo
que temos para desfrutar delas nós
trabalharmos mais viável passámos
demasiado as horas em frente ao
computador
passamos baseadas horas nas redes
sociais rever a ver a vida dos outros e
e eu percebo e estes fazedores a alguns
deles já unicorn por exemplo acontece
que já vão mais de mil milhões na semana
passada só que eu acho que eu acho que
eles vão eve uma dinâmica no início a
que me fazia acreditar que aumentava que
aumentava a proximidade das pessoas
normalmente quando os dois começam a
criar as próprias empresas
querem de todos os eventos querem a
conhecer e construir uma queda enorme de
contactos querem estar em todo o lado e
depois quando a mídia que a empresa vai
aumentando o número de pessoas ea partir
do momento em que o fazer já não pode
fazer tudo tem lugar
além de pedir ajuda a outras pessoas vai
perdendo vai primeiro desta esta
capacidade de mudar e só quando a
empresa creche a ponto de fazer o
primeiro olhar pra cima pra tudo aquilo
que construiu é que consegue fazer o
bibek da área dar volta ao mercado de
volta aquilo que sou hoje deram e eu
acho que estamos a chegar a este ponto
acho que acho que podemos podemos agora
dizer que a fase 2 que a questão é que
chega ao ponto de poderem ajudar o
mercado poderia fazer mais pelos outros
eu quero continuar a contar as histórias
deus
até eu será em todos a valer mais de mil
milhões de dólares e e não sabia que
tinha concelho e e tanto eu defendo
sendo 22 no dicionário
acho que podemos construir uma definição
do fazedor que nos que nos permita é
definiu como muito mais do que uma
pessoa que faz podemos podemos lutar por
essa idéia de incluir no dicionário uma
uma persona que alterou a maneira como
nós pensamos é o mundo e como o mundo vê
portugal e como nos treinos e eu pensei
que ela mais cedo então obrigada
[Aplausos]